[Music]
hello and a very warm welcome to this
latest edition of talking Germany the
show where we do just that my guest
today is a man who is both a very
successful scientist his specialist
field being
neuroscience and a very feisty
controversialist and here is that man in
person
Manfred Spitzer thank you very much for
joining us today here on talking Germany
coming all the way from the south of
Germany up to Berlin great to have you
here now aside from being one of
Germany's leading brain researchers
Manfred Spitzer has also made a name for
himself by arguing and I think arguing
is really the word that too much time
spent using computers mobile phones and
the internet will lead to what he calls
digital dementia digital dimension we'll
talk about that in a little bit I'd like
to start with her with a question that
you might not quite expect what is your
favorite novel that's a good question um
I liked the swarm the swarm explain what
the novel is about well it's it's it's
about oceans and oceanography and well
and catastrophic uhz the marine animals
basically want to get rid of human
beings because human beings are not good
for the earth okay you've convinced me
about your favorite novel the reason I'm
asking it's a bit of a cheeky question
is because I'm I'm wondering you're a
neuroscientist and you're also somebody
who's very much involved in the in the
in the social discourse by writing books
that are best-selling books how much
time do you actually have for reading
not a lot not a lot I have to confess
when I have spare time free time Sunday
afternoons I read science in nature
you read science in nature not novels
for fun for fun for fun yes and I love
it
I really love reading scientific
journals for fun okay the reason I'm
asking you all this is because I am a
little bit of a bookish person myself
and sometimes I feel a little bit
old-fashioned being a bookish person
these days and while I was researching
for the show reading about all the
things that you're interested in I came
up with a very very interesting quote
the quote is from Eric Schmidt of Google
the the the chairman of Google and what
he said was I
worry Eric Schmidt worries about the
sort of overwhelming rapidity of
information the especially stressful
information that we're getting that it
is moving us away from reading that we
are losing the habit of reading that had
an incredible effect on me it made me
very sad and I know that's the kind of
thing that you're very very interested
in tell me more
well I empathize with with what Eric
Schmidt said and I think he's also right
on targets emphasizing that it's a lack
of control
we whenever your digital gadget kind of
calls upon you you have to do this and
you have to do that yeah so it takes
over control of your life and this is
this is what people mean when they say
information overload from a brain
standpoint you cannot overload your
brain it shuts down itself
I mean it's if there's a certain amount
the brain can handle and if if there's
more it just it just doesn't do it yeah
but you can always have the feeling I
should do more and I should do this and
that and that and I am not in control of
all the things that happen and and this
is exactly the same thing as and in fact
it's identical to stress stress is not
the adversity that happens to you stress
is the lack of control and there are
even animal experiments in rats showing
this a rat in a cage who who can avoid
trucks by pressing a lever when when the
lamp lights up and when you do this the
rat will learn how to do it and it will
eventually it'll be slow and so it
sometimes you will get a shock now you
have a second read in another in another
room and that rat Gatz
gets a shock when this one gets one but
it can't avoid it it just it just gets a
shock so it hangs out and gets trucks
eventually now which of the two animals
will get stress symptoms from ulcers to
high blood pressure to eventually death
it's not that one who's paying attention
and tries to avoid no it's that one
because that one thinks I can do
whatever I want I get punched eventually
and this is what stress is all about and
this is increased by digital media and
this is not good for your health okay
you have been linked with this term
digital dementia yeah i you didn't coin
the term yourself where did you get it
from originally Korean scientists and
doctors Korean doctors noticed about six
years ago that there are a lot of young
men coming up and saying well I can't
concentrate I can't I tend to forget
things and I feel a bit like burnout and
and and they coined the term digital
dementia because these symptoms are
symptoms of dementia and and because
these young men always tell well I spend
a lot of time with computers and my free
time with computers so it was Korean
doctors okay so it's widespread in
career it's widespread in South Korea
which is a very digitally connected
Society
what about Germany how widespread is the
problem that you identify here in
Germany well almost as weisburd is in in
any developed country and while South
Koreans are probably the most advanced
in this advanced and in this respect
just to give you a figure the latest
numbers of internet and computer
addiction from South Korea is twenty
percent of the young folks and this is
not my data this data from their
Ministry of Health in Germany we have
maybe two three or four percent then 20
that's really amazing it's way up and it
exists since since my book about digital
dementia it came out in South Korea and
it was they were the first to have it
translated and after that I got mail
from South Korea and saying well we have
now a movement it's called one one one
and it's about young Korean people
saying okay we agree to shut off our
phone one day a week for one hour they
need a campaign for that okay to shut it
for one hour in one day a week okay well
tell me they see your University
Institute Inc in autumn in the southwest
of Germany where you work I know you do
a lot of sort of you do a lot of
research neuro research but you also do
clinical work with people who are you
know cutely addicted to new media I
think that's a fair way of putting again
well I'm the head of a run-of-the-mill
psychiatry yeah and tell me tell me what
it what that
what what that's like tell me what you
know what kind of pattern that is
somebody who is addicted to new media
well the ones that I see are the worst
cases because we are an acute hospital
so whenever somebody really
decompensates mentally he's brought to
my hospital and and I've seen young men
in their 20s late 20s that's by the way
the the standard they are the late 20s
they lost their job they lost their
apartment they lost all their friends
they play 18 hours of World of Warcraft
a day they have the waste bucket next to
the computer so they have don't have to
go to the toilet and you ask them do you
have friends yes have you ever met them
no and they are lives is complete ruined
and they are they come to the closed
ward so they they are locked up for a
week or two and they agree with that
because they know that's the only chance
and it's really amazing because once you
take away the teachers that they have no
way to cope and they are they get sort
of symptoms of cold turkey if you like
and it's it's it's really not a fun
thing I've talked to people and say ah
dr. Spitzer don't worry I mean these
people they would have been alcoholics
in the in the past or or they would
consume other drugs now they do
computers no it's the computer that's
the problem in their case and it's
really a bad problem okay addiction is
part of the human condition there's no
part there's no doubt about that but
what you're describing is indeed
depressing yeah without a doubt
there is another side there's a tension
here though because there's another side
to the story you rail you curse you damn
new media yeah well in in the use of it
and and the site one second yeah the
side effects you say are very very
dangerous but a new study yeah done by
the Max Planck Institute here in in
Germany the Max Planck Institute for
human development also by the
prestigious Charlotte a hospital has
just come out and it says video-gaming
causes increases increases
the brain regions responsible for
spatial orientation memory formation and
strategic planning as well as fine motor
skills that's quite a package it makes
me think I need more video gaming in my
life well first of all I'd like to read
the study mm-hm
second I'd like to know who sponsored
the study can there be anything in it
for you
yes um you know when you do a lot of
let's say shooting down space invaders
you get faster just as the British the
son of the Queen said Prince Harry he
was so good in his helicopter because he
has trained himself with the video games
mm-hmm
yes but you you were getting better at
reflex like action you do not get
getting you're not getting better at
planning that's one thing you're not
getting better at cognitive control that
is doing what you really want to do
pursuing aims and then go after your
goals in life you're not getting better
at that you're getting worse at that
you're you know people sometimes argue
let me let me give you this then people
sometimes argue well if if I if I get if
I'm getting better at getting this bad
guy in that bad guy because they come
from all over the place and my attention
is all over the place I said yes but
then you are training your attention to
be all over the place another word for
that for that is not being able to
concentrate because concentrating
involves your having your attention here
and not here and here and here
and in fact there's one paper that even
came out in the British science journal
of nature where the author argues that
you increase attention because you lose
the ability to focus on something well
this is called not being attentive often
though even though the author turns it
around and says well you you are better
at getting all the stuff in the
periphery yeah but one of the things
that you it's one of your hobby horses
you you you you get very sort of angry
when you talk about multitasking and the
impact of
multitasking sometimes in it in human
can't the abyss you say humans come but
I mean in in the comfort of my own home
I cook a meal I listen to music I chat
to a friend and that's called relaxation
for me and I'm doing three different
things at the same time it's not
multitasking multitasking in a strict
sense of course many people can do all
kinds of things at the same time that
that's that's that's not but
multitasking in a strict sense is about
and let me tell you why I think
multitasking in strict sense is at issue
because when we are deal with digital
media we deal with narrative we deal
with words we live with content with a
meaning and what human brains cannot do
what human beings cannot do is follow to
to content to two stories at the same
time there's a reason why here's nobody
sitting and talking to you at the same
time as I am doing because it you
couldn't cope with two with two people
talking with two people that's not
possible and in psychology there are
experiments showing that if you try your
performance gets worse nobody reads two
books at the same time because you can
and if you do for an hour you got less
than if you had read half an hour this
book and half for now that book I mean
that's that's shown a hundred times so
that type of multitasking doing to
contents at the same time consciously is
not part not even for women okay it's
not possible so and that's what
computers demand of you and which is why
the New York Times reported in 2009 that
the US economy loses 650 billion million
dollar a year because all the employees
try multitasking and the performance
gets worse
[Music]
man for its spirit so tell me again in
your own words why the early phase the
early years of a child's education is so
very very important well the brain
doesn't come ready-made when you were
born it comes with the possibility of
development and that development happens
only if you have well stimuli and most
importantly it's not just colors and and
and and sounds it is coordinated stimuli
that is this is a class and I can do
this so I I feel it I hear it I have the
touch and I have well I could have smell
if it was something else and etc etc and
I see it of course so and babies need
this holistic type of input because the
baby's brain kind of try learns how to
how to listen in seeing and and all the
senses they get the input is brought
together in the baby's brain and which
is how the baby learns how the world is
and what how its well how it works
mmm if you give the baby just the image
of it and maybe a bit sound and and the
image is here and the sound is there the
baby's brain won't be able to combine
that it can only combine it if it's
really here and the same which is why
it's so important to have babies
interact with the real world rather than
well the digital version of it and that
cannot in no way in US adults yes but
but in babies in no way can the digital
input replace real world which is why
it's almost it's almost a crime to have
a baby or put it in front of an eye of
an iPad and have it the Swiper because
it's as in the in the in the little film
with which we see so you have to use
your hand because you learn to come to
grips with something and this is really
important it's using using your hand is
it's it's it's a greatest tool and the
great sense organ and that builds up our
brain it builds up the connections and
this is what what you and I use when we
talk and feel and which doesn't get its
full development when you interact too
much with the digital world okay so we
need a which is why digital media are
not
good the younger you are the verse they
are hmm so we need feeling touching
active stimuli for young children for
the youngest children on the other hand
what we learnt in that report as well is
that fear and we come back to the same
word you used earlier stress fear and
stress are a block to creativity yes
after learning how does that work well
stress kills neurons that's one thing
and so that's very bad for learning and
fear associate well you know if if
something really frightening goes on
it's not good when you relax and think
of possible solutions I mean those who
did that in our past they got eaten by
the saber-toothed tiger
so you when you wait when that thing is
around you better run and think of
nothing but running okay which is why
fear shuts off remote associations shuts
off our whole remotely thought processes
we only think of one thing so fear
interferes with creativity it basically
shuts down creative thoughts so if you
want to be creative you must be fearful
for one thing if you want to teach
somebody something that the person will
be able to use creatively later on you
must not use anxiety or fear in training
because if you learn something under
fear you basically save the fear
together with the input and then you
will recall the fear with the input and
then you'll be not able to use that
input creatively so if you teach and you
use anxiety and you threaten people you
can just as well just don't teach
because what you teach will not be of
interest because that would be my next
question to what extent are the lessons
you've just been teaching me about good
education you are one of the leading you
know experts in the field of brain
research in Germany you're also a voice
in the field of sort of Education and
what have you yeah yeah to what extent
to those lessons that you're outlining
here being applied in German schools or
not they're not they're not they're not
no but why not well I think good
teachers know about these things and
they do it because they realize by you
know by doing it
it's really not good to threaten
children or to put the pressure on them
but the system does and that's why many
teachers kind of get symptoms of stress
and get depressed because they realize
within the system that they are in they
have a hard time realizing good good
teaching and good learning because the
system puts a lot of pressure onto the
kids which is not good for learning okay
what a you've mentioned it in passing a
wee little bit computers in schools yeah
everybody it's a common place everybody
says we need computers in schools
because that is where you know the
digital world is the world where we're
doing business these days it's where
we're having ideas it's where we're
creating jobs so we need computers in
schools at an early age you say no
exactly well well my point is this in
order to use computers you need you need
to have one thing that's knowledge let
take Google when you do a Google search
you do not need to know anything about
computers because you know how to use
Google you click on the browser and then
there's this and if you type in your
question if you know nothing you have no
question so you need not go Google
anyway but if you know a bit Google is
very it's not very useful simply because
you have to know a lot when Google froze
ten thousand hits at you once in half a
second or so because once Google has
answered your question then it's you to
filter out the wheat from the chaff and
you can only do this by knowing
something the more you know the better
you are able to use Google now that how
does knowledge come into my brain or in
the into the brains of young young
people and now the point is not using
Google because we know there's a nice
science paper out in 2011 researchers
from Harvard and Columbia showed that if
you use Google to acquire knowledge you
tend to forget that simply because your
brain thinks oh well I can google that
and this is this little incentive to
memorize ok when you read a book you
know I don't carry this with me all the
time so I better memorize ok so just to
make the argument if you if you need
knowledge to Google and if Google is not
good for knowledge
acquisition then there's one thing you
must not do in schools I just use Google
what age would you allow computers to be
introduced into German schools if the
Education Minister came and said give me
an age that would be well 8020 Rosamond
Oh 18 would be the safe side 18 18 the
peas our data show that a computer if
you give a 15 year old a computer his
school grades will be verse will get
verse we know that so 15 is too young
and we have other data showing that okay
anything else is advertisement and
popular PR by the computer industry I
know that many even many people in
education will say we need computers at
an early age but there's no absolutely
no evidence that this does any good to
the education of kids kids no evidence
in fact in Silicon Valley there's a
Valder school and it advertises we have
no computers here and all the computer
giant's the buses kids go to this school
because it's a good school they do with
theater and music and sports and this is
what young people need computers is what
they don't need so if you ask me what's
the early age well 18 we are adult and
we can do 18 is is too old maybe and 15
is too young so between 15 and 18 and if
you think about it that makes probably a
lot of sense
[Music]
another one of your specialities music
music and the brain yeah why is music so
good for the kind of learning that we've
just been listening to hearing about for
a lot of reasons actually what we do
know by now is that that musical
training enhances your IQ that it's not
the Mozart Effect but it's it's it's
definitely giving you a few points in an
IQ which has been shown by controlled
studies so it's so we do know that and
and we also know that music regulates
your affect in a sort of a middle range
way so it's able to swing up and down
which is what you need for learning to
attach well good and bad two things you
need your emotions going up and down and
which that happens and it happens with
music that that's a good thing
music is is stimulating for your entire
brain we do not have a music center if
the whole brain lights up when you do
music so you train your brain and in a
quite a few respects when you when you
practice music active is better than
passive but passive has a few effects
too so music is a great thing for your
brain absolutely yes and it was
interesting what one of the guys said in
there in that report he said the more I
learn the easier it gets that's
interesting well this is how elderly
people and with it I mean everyone over
seventeen roughly learn I think about it
our brains learn quickly when we are
young everyone knows that and then you
get older and then you learn much slower
but the thing is the interesting thing
is this who can learn a second or a
language better well though those people
he who knows already five and who can
learn new music in smells but he who
knows already five so the brain is is a
strange thing a hard drive if it's half
full
only it has only half the space but our
brain the mores in there the better you
learn so it's kind of a paradox storage
device the more it's there the more fits
in
which is which is why you need a lot of
being in there to be a lifelong learner
that is if you are 17 and nothing's in
there you will have a hard time learning
at all it's interesting what you're
saying that because I did come across
another what I was reading up on all
this I came across another quote that
interested me an awful lot from a Dutch
educationalist a woman called greenie
curse milder she said lifelong learning
what you're talking about is about
navigating in a changing world right
would you make of that yeah that's
that's a good idea or a good way to
phrase it and I would even say it's it's
it's it's really important to know that
world I mean to stick with this metaphor
and you better you know the world
already the better you are at navigating
in the future with and and the more you
know the more you can learn so if no one
has ever argued well I know five
languages so my language centers are
full yeah
I'm not capable of learning a six I mean
it's it sounds even funny if I just say
this so this shows you that our brains
are really different from any other
storage device it's interesting though
because you we're talking about lifelong
learning and you and you said you want
to keep computers out of the classroom
away from kids pretty much through to
age 18 or maybe but for the elderly yeah
learning to use a computer and doing so
actually using the commute could the
computer in the social media and all the
possibilities that exist is a great
thing it can be varied for my mother
it's liberating and that's very typical
yeah that kind of experience I would
never deny an elderly person to do to
learn how to use a computer for well
writing letters and having social
exchanges and all that
I mean learning for elderly people is
good and learning to use a computer is
just one instance of learning and so
that's not bad at all
I'm just saying there are risks and side
effects with a young with the with the
kids and the nd in the adolescence and
these risk and side-effects are huge
that's all I'm saying you're a brain
researcher and you're somebody who knows
how much we've achieved or not achieved
in the battle that preoccupies many
people in an aging society the battle
against dementia is that a battle that
can be won in any way or is that do we
simply have to accept that with that in
an aging society that's going to be an
it's going to be a facet
of our lives well yes yes and no where's
the German say for one thing brains do
deteriorate with age and then there on
top of that there are a lot of diseases
that kill brain cells like Alzheimer's
like infarctions or whatever but the
important point is one you don't need
your entire brain to function brains
have the the feature of graceful
degradation an interesting phrase yeah
it's actually it's called that's a
technical term graceful degradation it
and and the opposite is crash I mean
computers crash rains don't crash they
degrade gracefully that is you lose half
of your neurons and you don't notice it
and when and let's take Parkinson's
disease you notice you have some
something is strange with your motor
well motor capabilities when 70% of the
neurons that die in Parkinson's is
already dead okay that's what that's
graceful degradation and same thing with
Alzheimer's disease you can use half of
your neurons you're perfectly fine and
then you and if more goes down the tubes
then all of a sudden you will get
symptoms of dementia but the more
developed connected trained up your
brain is the higher you are in your
mental capability the longer it takes if
you take dementia means mental decline
okay which is why we need that training
as young people to avoid dementia in old
age let me give you an example if you
know two languages and you get
Alzheimer's you get it five years later
so that you would get you got early
training and you use those two languages
and then you get your all-time files as
free studies out on hundreds of people
showing this in several several
countries always the same thing five
years the second language gives you five
years dementia free life if you get
Alzheimer's
[Music]
my preach Pizza the reason why we're
running this report on the show is
because you grew up in what the Germans
call a gross familiar in an extended
family and you now have a very big
family yourself let's talk about your
the one you grew up in first what was it
like we were nine people to
grandmother's father and mother and we
were five children and we were well
there were always nine people I mean
it's really amazing when we had when we
had let's say Christmas or celebrated a
New Year's Eve or something that was us
we were old pictures where I'm dancing
with my grandmother and I was there but
that was just how life was and it was
good it was really good it made you into
the person you are I think Emily yes I'm
guessing because because there must have
been sort of levels of communication
that were very interactive yes yes and
it were a lot of well occasions for well
for humor or for interesting things or
doing things it was never boring I mean
I always was something going on sure yes
and and that's how life is and that's
how I like it yes and now you have six
kids of your own well I have to say I
had five and they are now all grown up
now I have a second I have a 6-1 and
she's five and but with those five kids
yeah we had a lot of fun of course it's
not easy but but I would I would
definitely do it over again like like we
did I envy you
I have two kids myself and if I could
live my life again I would I would like
to have more kids yeah for sure but in
that report what we learnt is that many
people here in Germany they wag their
finger at you or they frown at you or
whatever for having this big family
that's what it said in that report is
that true mmm well I experienced that in
the u.s. I tended to say well we are
neither dumb nor fundamentally religious
when I was asked how many kids I have
uh-huh so really and because that was
the suspicion then that but it never
happened in Germany probably because it
Germany was was a country with with
extended families and that happened only
in the last decades they
that our birth rate will you want and
when you talk about suspicion at least
what people think when they see big
families like somebody like you with
your six kids in tow yeah I think
probably what most people think these
days is he must be relatively well off
because it's knitted normally people who
are relatively well-off who can afford
to have big families these days I think
there's been a sort of a shift there no
yeah well I tell you the story when I
was claiming the right to be a father of
my sixth child because I wasn't married
with the mother I I went to the agency
and the woman flipped through my charts
and said well this is your sixth child
and she was thinking this must be the
hit and run person the and and then she
professor so she she really didn't know
what to make out of this that was pretty
as he was kind of confused as I am so so
yes there is this attitude against
against people with with many kids but I
think in general people people are for
extended families definitely in Germany
yeah okay
I certainly am you like to ask our
guests to bring along something
interesting something cherished a
possession of theirs and you have chosen
to bring along that thing down there
my little pocket clarinet also called
chalumeau I built it and and I like
doing these things of working with wood
and to yourself yeah yes yes you take a
piece of water this is unusual for a
neuroscientist to be yea engaged in
handicrafts yeah well maybe I don't know
but it's fun to do this I mean it's
really fun and um well let me try to get
something or good well anyway it sounds
like a claret you know they say time is
ticking away I'd like to ask you the
following question because we've talked
about it in general it give me one tip
for how in our lives in general young
and old we can remain also in terms of
our brains and our our emotional
activity fit healthy and active be
together
be together loneliness is the major
killer yes be together
old and young together that's really
what helps you a lot not crossword
puzzles and no pseudo Co get yourself a
young kid and a grandchild a grandchild
is a lifesaver and the the thing against
Alzheimer's okay a one more question we
don't have a quiz at the end of the show
but I'm more interested in this question
how much of the brain is still
undiscovered a lot I'll leave it in fact
here that is your lot with the eloquent
and controversial manfred spitzer
there's more talking German eight
including my blog on and our archived on
the website now you might also like to
watch the German version of the show
with my colleague IO sure if you've
enjoyed today's show as much as I have
come back next week bye bye juice
[Music]
you